bernard tapie ancien membre des
jeunesses communistes s de 29 aces de
l'afo anne brochet à toi de jouer
info info oui un petit étoiles peuvent
un top ce que tu m'as dit info un bon on
va écouter l'expert mesdames messieurs
vous ne retrouverez pas philippe guérin
ce soir notre expert est malade et ce
n'est pas de l'intox
philippe si tu nous regardes et je sais
que tu nous regardes sache qu'on pense
beaucoup à toi
voici donc notre nouvel expert jacky
nercessian
l'un d'eux à aller
est-ce que tu as commentaires jacky en
effet en 1962 bernard tapie était
beaucoup plus préoccupé par sa rencontre
daniel filipacchi pour entrer dans le
hit parade de salut les copains
ceci dit bernard tapie est actuellement
très préoccupée par la montée fulgurante
de l'as monaco
je suis sûr qu'il est prêt à faire un
pont d'or au parti communiste français
pour racheter georges marchais et pour
le revendre au franc symbolique comme
gardien de but à l'as monaco bonne
affaire d'agression ça fait 1 0 pour
hypo malin bravo hip hop
ban